so you can move hello and welcome back
to art appreciation with Chris Redfield
here we have Van Gogh's skeleton
skeleton on the plains I would pay money
to have that in my room they look like
they're having a great time like not
only is he searching for treasure
there's a normal intro but he's like
searching for it essentially yeah so
apparently Chris Redfield zidle
animation in code Veronica X or code
Veronica he crosses his arms like that
and it looks like he's actually looking
at this piece of art that Mary's has
been doting on for like an hour it's
quite great we've got what this one too
you can see so what'd we do last time
oh yeah last time you ran into some
spiders hi everyone this is resin
Knievel episode you're probably confused
you made the halberd so so I'm full I
remember this actually I remember this
vividly because there is a plant over
here and there was like a lot and there
are these spies under there that were
gross and I have all these freaking ink
ribbons taking up a lot of space and I
have grenades I need to get to a box
essentially so I can drop some of this
stuff off I'm like completely and
utterly full it's probably worth coming
back for the herb after and I did save
but I don't remember what I'm supposed
to do with this halberd oh it's a key
down in the basement where that shotgun
wall thing was you'd go past the save
room and that's where you're trying to
go okay so far well that save rooms have
a box because then it kind of suits the
purpose
okay and then the only other thing I
needed to remember is what are the odds
that I'm in serious trouble I don't
think you're gonna run into too much on
the way back there okay I've been wrong
before though yeah someone over the
weekend started resident evil like from
episode 1 is like hey dude you ruin this
feature by your Guiding in apostrophes
become the point
I mean migrate till they get to resin
evil 5 there is Sheva for the rest
someone reminded me of
resident evil 3 where I was I was like
straight-up spent 50 minutes dying
before the new advice was run away
you're to [ __ ] at this game and it was
the worst feeling in the world I think
I've ever felt more like a failure okay
so I think you're going down that ladder
so there's the elevator
oh also people told us to go back to the
garage to get back to the sub machine
right because I still have them we
couldn't get there can I get there now I
think we could we just didn't know how
to do we know how new cuz I don't know
how we tried and we couldn't do it go
toward the garage and I'll look it up
I'm just saying that you what garage
where Steve was the so see this hole I
can't get past that hole I wish I could
zoom in on this map but like the whole I
think use that elevator anyway yeah I
mean you're gonna have to use the
elevator to the right okay so I'm going
down the elevator yeah
you also reminded me that am I going to
basement or for to so floor to so then
if you're getting submachine guns oh do
you want to drop stuff off first or but
afford I can't pick up them smeb
submachine guns
yeah happens so often oh you were saying
that we were getting to our almost our
100th episode we're like getting there
yeah this is our uh we're not there but
we're like this is our 94th I can't drop
that right yeah there's like a garden
thing yeah I believe this is our 94 it's
crazy this is confusing me I'm saying
okay
there's one guy here there is one guy
but I don't know what I'm doing where do
you want me to go over here there isn't
there like two bad guys in here I don't
you can get down there without the I'm
just trying to get to a box oh if I
could just remind you oh yeah I just
want to get to a say box but there's no
safe box in here then maybe have to go
upstairs the end of a long hallway over
here I got this idiot I think this is
the right way I honestly well we're
gonna find out going up the ladder yeah
you'll come up your ass a broom I'll be
outside
oh you're near the hole you have no idea
where we are
no but you seem to know where we're
going something to let you but I don't
know oh they're just save room at the
bottom of the elevator out here right no
I have no idea we what you're telling me
to do right now there's no safe box even
remotely close to this yeah just go
through here go outside and then we can
go into the garage from here the
elevator is broken isn't it or something
you don't need an elevator or you will
but it's not the one we thought don't in
this hole the old number those are
motion sensing turrets no they're gone
the cameras that called hunter site
they're gone
I forgot where I was going is it in here
yes yes no you were going the right way
you gotta go that way where to where the
tank was mmm the tank yard we can't [ __ ]
this up I thought that door was long
you're the one playing boy this is a
joint failure that door is locked
yeah totally that's why oh yeah you
gotta go so down the elevator to the
saver yeah drop stuff off that's where
we're going
that's the fastest and safest one you
could find the 1x2 of these yellow
[ __ ] well I guess they're purple it
took a little bit of demos on that
Thomas J I don't know that was worth it
I feel like I just like totally bid it
let's find out I look
moderately hurt and find out I think I
got two slashes of Health okay okay here
we go
planet mixer on YouTube go to the area
where you placed a battery pack go down
at where Steve killed his dad and as a
zombie there's two doors there so
apparently we were really close and we
just didn't go through the right door I
[Music]
remember that part
yeah planet is on YouTube thank you
you've been helpful are you kidding
where is this [ __ ] oh it was in the
other place I was like where am I so I
went all the way here I'm gonna take a
[ __ ] ton of damage to like put some
stuff in a box I can't believe this is
the closest like box I mean there's no
doubt in my mind
so Nathan Shepard I don't I should call
you out more often but you're doing the
Lord's work with your stats keep playing
okay I'm gonna sorry I mean that I felt
like it was a bit hostile so how many
times do you think you've died do not
look at the screen okay um over 10 yeah
but uh 2015 you underestimate yourself
how many kills you think you have I mean
zombies dogs banner smooches moths Todd
40 179 100 you have murderer you have a
hundred thirty-eight zombies eight dogs
11 smooches five moths one tyrant five
black widows the Nosferatu dude thank
you a gulp worm oh the golf worm nine
hunters and you got chewed on by zoms
fifty four times use hell 32 times 23
saves and then PS Thank You Nathan the
path leading to the Ingram submachine
guns is in the garage which is actually
an route to where you need to go next
the tank yard don't the tank you are
next
I don't know oh that's what the hell
bird door is where so okay I know how to
get there yeah so
just tell me where I need to go back to
the elevator and take it to the second
floor so you can go to the garage can't
walk and take that like the mechanical
elevator thing down you don't talk about
when it raises it like forms the catwalk
let's you'll remember let's start with
I'm gonna go up this elevator and I'm
gonna [ __ ] stab by these two a-holes
and I need to get to the same door I
came from right right you do need to go
past the hunters yes don't go down don't
go down what are you going up the
elevator right now well this yeah are
you almost dead yeah you have to dodge
two sweepers I got it this could be tell
me how many deaths I have and then shut
up fifteen that's right
are you saying you're gonna add one no
I'm saying that's where it ends don't
babe ruth's call it out if you're gonna
get destroyed like what is this Babe
Ruth had more strikeouts than any other
you miss 100% of the shots you don't
take
Wayne Gretzky Michael Scott Mike McCarty
Babe Ruth
do you miss 2% of the shots you don't
take
hey brick idiot now we can't play no
more what I wouldn't worry what are you
what about your history with this series
do you think you were capable of doing
it listen this is a good opportunity for
you take me to a better save box yeah
fair enough
um go - okay okay
let me actually think for a sec hey
so elevator I mean that's the only
option you have right now
God elevator to the second floor there's
nothing that's the way I did last
elevator to the basement then ya know
you went to the basement you definitely
watch the basement second floor is safe
room and submachine guns and the helmet
you went to the basement last night no
because remember you yes you didn't go
up here damn it
wait we should be one around here right
oh it's across the is it in here and
then I take the thingy down so that's
where you get to the submachine guns
that's what I was it's not where the
saved boxes isn't there a save room in
here is there I don't know your map
should show us a box now but I'm on the
top floor that's what I was saying later
so I don't know but if I go in here and
I lower the lift so this is the part
apparently we were really close to God
bless it I wish I was wrong less is it
that pink thing is that the elevator out
in the tank yard or go through the
double doors you know I mean no to the
left of the camera right now there
what's Thursday yeah but what's through
there I can't remember it's around here
this is where people are telling us in
the comments god we were close
please don't have anything that oh yeah
it's down here okay sweet Thank You
Nathan Shepherd and Planet mixer and
there was other people to you like on
Twitter that were mentioning as well
Albert Laura recommended out going back
okay
sweet sweet okay so there's a lock
there's a box here there's a box yeah
and there's it's near a statue
okay well let's know he's it's amazing
that when you kill a a monster they
disappear but the humans just their
bodies just hang out forever so it's in
here beautiful maybe it's over well I
gotta get rid of this [ __ ] anyway so let
me do that and then you're also close to
where you're going so this worked out
really well this is great I'm glad that
I wiped totally on purpose I don't think
you'll need your bow honestly yeah
that's a good point it's only got four
in it anyway it's totally useless I
don't have a lot of bullies though you
got a lot of shotgun shells I do I'm
sorry
so I think it's back toward the camera
that is what they're saying yes
statue
what do you put in there I wonder I
think come back farther this way there
is like a little around the corner okay
so there's it's like a ball how do you
have a lighter
yes maybe it's a torch oh okay that one
you did help me okay that makes me feel
a lot better if you have a lot of health
oh you're gonna hate me do you want to
go back to that green herb though in the
room we started today out in no really
yeah you're confident today I dig it
I guess we could don't go do the Helberg
here morale is high and deaths are at 16
let's do it oh yeah Nathan record that
one death by sweeper street sweeper
social club he got me so I only got one
free space no wait I got I can convince
don't but don't come by them just for
this play because yeah I guess so
green and red are better together anyway
alright so the question is is do I need
these now because it takes two slots
[Music]
like I could take seven shotgun shells
all of my honestly I don't wanna spoil
anything I don't think it matters what
you have right now as long as you have
free spaces free you're fine right now
or three free with em so I think did you
say free or three three three three did
you say yes sir yeah sure did you say
Abe Lincoln hey do you know what those
are called when you mistake words like
that a mondegreen a mondegreen yes so
like Amanda green no so it's from an old
poem I forget what but like when you
miss hear song lyrics and you think it
they said like whatever like what you
just did you will
there's a reason poem that said she laid
him on the green like a blonde but
someone heard it and thought it was lady
mondegreen so the words that's cool
I learned that forgot how mondegreen all
right where am I going
I don't know question out to the tank
yard I think do you know a song where
they're like my car was in fry yard my
sister thought about Sunday where no
wait no my pit my sister thought that
the lyrics were every now and again I
kicked the livin [ __ ] happy instead of
[ __ ] out of me
and it's still like a funny thing that
we say to her is like oh [ __ ]
blink-182 yeah please tell me yeah we on
the mana green yeah god I hope in [ __ ]
happy that's the classic that's I think
you're going out the door out the door
okay all right let's do it
so I think the whatever the I think the
tank went into the ground when you did
that hole
you know it's still there pretty sure
your objective somewhere out here though
okay because the help like behind the
tank maybe ok [ __ ] can we just get into
the tank and solve everything that makes
more sense
is it down this elevator okay and then
there should be a safe room and then
there should be a help I don't have any
pucks cuz I didn't take them with me so
hopefully that's okay
Oh God okay I remember this area I
remember this and then there's there's a
so wait hold on open it the halberd door
should be around here ish it's the green
thing okay do you want you want me to
say before I do this though sure I don't
have to yeah you have a lot you're 13
you're 12
yeah how much more the game do I have
left though you should save you weren't
getting there we're not like at the end
of my any means but word what what's the
longest season of knievel by game do you
know does any no oh like the most
episodes like if it took like 17
episodes to finish was it six five felt
to was pretty quick six was so long and
we didn't even totally finish it I have
no regrets about that by the way like
what a horribly long game - like just
suffer through it what's weird is I did
play a little bit of six when I was
younger when it came out and I remember
being like this is cool like what a cool
game because I had like never played one
before us I didn't understand why
everyone hated it so much yeah but going
back to it after playing the previous
ones
it's like unfunctional you became a
resonable fan in that interim I just
realized what good is like design was
for this series for this series
yeah wait what jong-kook why do you have
one ribbon left no no you're good I
saved 13 times or something you do I do
but I can go back if you want to see it
Taleb or 1972 says mike little advice
start using walk there before recording
that defeats the spirit of the whole
thing
Oh like read it you spend a lot of your
time readings zero is a number Mary
don't be stupid shut up Steven Sanders
[Laughter]
sweet cutscene what where do you think
we're going
Jamaica on Claire all see that wasn't me
it's also a ventriloquist
[ __ ] yeah listen to this [ __ ]
he's like drinking a glass of water
love you Claire
[Music]
oh so the elevator went up
[Music]
do you think we were going to the moon
for a second a little bit it was kind of
like an ET moment so we can't go back
your stuff will be in the same box is
that not that green herb though that's
why I recommend it going hey did you
know I wasn't ever coming back
and I [ __ ] it
Eagle logos on the jet the Harrier
this is the hangar where Claire was
before
[Music]
it's really cool to reuse all these old
locations in unique ways sweet wearing
at Antarctica little advice start using
walk through before according thanks for
the advice I never thought about what is
that definitely not supposed to go this
way I don't think can I get around it no
you just got hit what are you doing I
don't know I thought can I shoot it no
just go the other way there's another
door though there's known it is always
there I wasn't even watching Mike maybe
you should read walkthrough before we
start recording there's a door right
there there's how we came from where are
you
there's other doors oh yeah maybe is
that door right there
no you were not looking when I tried to
go through there where you know I know
everyone knows the audience knows we all
know don't don't chew the shotgun though
like I'm gonna try alright you can light
it on fire
well why do you still let the hell dirt
I don't know maybe use it again you're
right wait is it gonna do anything feel
like I'm wasting these bullies what it
wants what if I'm wasting like bullets
is this really yeah God imagine what was
that I said is it growing out of the
flakes oh my god I'm hurt now I I didn't
see it come on caution now sucks is it
can I do it
No do you know I thought I had it
listen if one of us read the thing
before we started one of us wouldn't be
on caution it also wouldn't be nearly as
fun of a series I like going off my
fault then let me try to get around the
squid alright this whole series about
backseat what am I saying should I go
this way or the other way that big
dead-end room first like stairs near it
too it looks like yeah I guess check the
room out
I'm a little hurt who hurt you close
quarters Abed
oh I remember this is their lockers and
stuffing are their lockers and stuffing
you remember this Oh No
but you didn't come in here as Claire
yeah this is like I there was aa when I
came in here remember they were like
crawling around and [ __ ] good idea
- good idea useless books not a reader a
oh it's just books we'll take both wait
are you Paul now
yes but I'm also hurt so I could no
he'll know okay well then I'll just
leave those grenades there for now it's
fine I'm sure there's gonna be a box
somewhere around here I can't make me go
forever like this I'm going downstairs
wait look at the map again so downstairs
its own area and then this area has like
multiple corridors explore upstairs okay
let's check it out
it's another door we're gonna cuz we're
going above another floor hey I remember
this I remember this this is where she
is isn't she
or wait she tunneled out or she got
stuck did have an eclair
now she escaped with Steve right oh she
escaped in the plane and then the
tentacles knocked her down that's what
it was right
the monster yeah yeah like came out of
nowhere after they had like already left
and stuff feels like I should have a
mask on do you hear this music
alright I'll do that
now if this was divinity I would slip
over this is super creepy they've done a
good job with us can I run no slide
action they [ __ ] up I got one how do
you have one because I didn't take the
grenades nice foresight pink and a
foreskin
[Music]
those guys are sketching me out I know
Oh balls
Oh will I ever come back here cuz that
part of me wants to just not deal with
it oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it really doesn't
look like you if you're confident you're
dodging I wouldn't oh oh you [ __ ] what
is that is he eating the bug off of me
because that would be great man you are
not all right I'm gonna die I'm actually
gonna die I think I need to thingy no
you know you might need to fire it nice
now I'd go or make oh my fix right yeah
there's a nice that was a well-used
shotgun shell thank you it's hard to
tell open your mouth so there was an
extra little space in here yeah it's
probably something save so what was that
bug all about
you're not poisoned are you let's find
out no you you have since no well
sometimes it happens later that was
gross wasn't it facehugger it was a back
hugger
I don't see anything in here oh it's
like a turbine yeah but why is this room
exists no and this is where I was this
is where I was when we couldn't find the
thing and we looked for like ever
for like 15 minutes and we went in and
out of this room yeah maybe but I don't
remember being able to use oh god what
if they've like sucked up this area now
that I've gone in here stay in the pool
stay in the pool okay I haven't been in
here you'd think that the doors would be
like a little icy Oh balls okay should I
change to like a gun because I'd rather
have the shotgun I don't know if I'm
hitting them it's hard to tell
Wow for [ __ ] sake Larry I really feel
like hardhat you from powers I backed up
the wrong way I got it I got it I got it
stomping done oh so okay took one little
nibble one nib oh god okay wait up that
was unexpected the first shot is always
a warning shot come on come on come on
come on
thank you all right and I don't hear any
other use so I think we're good geez I
hope there's something good in here I
spent like a lot of bullets wait is
there nothing in here there's still the
cage I saw a case in the cage with his
aunties Tina I remember the cage is
locked when Claire was here yes I do
I thought I opened it though
a briefcase maybe I shouldn't have taken
that you oh yeah that's right
as I as expected you're just testing me
yes your resolve
[Music]
this is it that's it I've done
everything down here sorry I'm getting
bored while you backtrack typed me a
secret message to go [ __ ] myself I want
everyone to know what he just did yep
bored when you were backpacking okay
there's a safe room around here I think
anyway it's probably on stairs at this
point you're bad man Chris really enjoys
taking those stairs slowly this is moth
country can't stop here oh yeah actually
it is
I know yeah you have been here mate yes
but I hope these moths are dead
sounds like it God they suck but just in
case they're here let's we'll walk it a
leisurely stroll I'm just you know
investigating the moth situation Hey Oh
also the halberd goes in here it does
I'm almost positive um I don't know what
to do with this case inspect it it
probably needs a okay
maybe you'll get the lockpick now no
check damn I don't even know if we're
supposed to have that yet
I mean the worst thing that happens is I
put it in the save box and then when I
become the girl I can open it right so
it's not like a huge deal
all right so oh sorry
is it right in here that's cool let's
fill this give you
hockey pucks that's good a paper wing
elección Alfred
American Airlines paperweight that's
very close to the American Airlines logo
there is a sealed room in the hallway
located inside of the Antarctic facility
I don't know what is hidden there but I
do know how to get in then why don't you
know what's in there
I can use the three jewels that each one
of our three family members wear as
proof of being a legitimate descendant
of the Ashford family the only problem
is I don't know how I can gain
possession of my father's proof finally
succeeded in entering that sealed room I
could never have imagined that such an
insane secret existed regarding the
birth of both Alexia and myself I hate
my father that fool Alexander now it's
obvious that we were merely created in
an attempt to cover my father's blunder
I could never trust him again but I must
regain the glory of the Ashford family
with my C stern I have nothing to be
afraid of as long as Alexia is with me
Alexia carried out the experiment on the
human body that we've been talking about
our useless father must be happy now
since weak he can finally contribute to
the Ashford family oh say I did some
[ __ ] to him the only thing that should
be careful about is that the Butler
Harmon does not become wise the
experiment resulted in failure our
Father was useless after all
even worse he turned into a dangerous
monster that's completely out of control
we tied him down and locked him in an
underground prison cell however Alexia
seems to be close to solution beyond all
that expectation she says that she
wishes to conduct the experiment on her
own body on top of that she feels she
must be kept asleep for the 15 years in
order to accomplish the experiment
thanks to that idiot I can't see my dear
Alexia for as long as 15 years Lexi is
going to sleep with all of her trust
relying upon me now the only one who can
protect Alexia my god
all right what the hell am I doing with
this dice there's a lot to unpack here
the good news is is we got some pucks
and we got this dice you might as well
check it this die no I didn't want to do
that I didn't want to do that
American Airlines gesture little hearts
umbrella all right well this is a weird
die
okay should I keep it for now
I don't know where you going next well I
was gonna see if that guy was still down
there Oh doesn't look like it does it no
that was really creepy though at the
time when that was happening I hated it
I hate it going in there remember what
he knocked you off the helipad I need to
you know just making sure dude had some
long arms I'll tell you that all right
I'm putting the dice away if you think I
need it let me know do you have the
grenade launcher no I forgot okay ooh
I saw he looks at danger so I wonder if
that's connected he's gonna fall no he's
definitely shoot it no don't shoot it
okay
that's all right what am i doing
wait he shot a thingy oh my god I don't
know what to do
just mash buttons without shooting I
think it it'll
okay I got him I did have to shoot once
though well let's see if I'm poisoned
okay doesn't look like I'm poisoned [ __ ]
so I'm gonna be honest with you I don't
know where to go so we went downstairs I
found the save room I got the dye and I
got a gas or dingy opener so I'm fairly
certain because it's frozen now you can
cross that hole in the catwalk between
those two doors in the big room in this
room yeah like it wasn't frozen before
it wasn't like I flooded the room I
guess so and it froze do you go through
here the ladder right there I think
you're right you didn't do it personally
I just I think it happened when you
crashed back or something I don't know
so you so this is frozen instead of
being like a second floor so I'm pretty
sure he's like cross right there yeah
there you go
okay so there's two more before you go
through this door what is that spider
but it doesn't make sense why would just
them why is it so big he's got two
penises go check this room at the end
what about this room that's where you're
going but there's no this is a dead end
I don't see everything worthwhile here
get in there you dum-dum
oh my god I'm gonna have to crack this
ice aren't I yeah probably oh that thing
was awful wasn't it just awful
I think spiders and oh [ __ ] off
oh oh
no no no no no no no no no hunters
shotgun
that's unfair reload please
not [ __ ]
oh my god
oh my god died Jesus
nice hopefully that thing doesn't
reactivate geez but we know Wesker's
here alright so am i going left here or
finishing the hallway looks like a save
room at the end of the hallway right uh
maybe I'd say I'd say just go to
Authority right for now I'm assuming it
doesn't look like you're gonna go much
farther this is probably an item here
you can use little concerned
[Music]
okay that goes downstairs or something
look at that shiny
what's that see that blood I'm gonna go
up first does it go up or down it looks
so confused it looks like it'll bring
you up there Oh God
do you have it you know the valve on you
do you I don't I didn't bring it all
right now we know what to do
oh it's square okay wait go back to it
sorry that's it's square though
unless they miss wrote it your octagonal
one's not gonna fit
oh [ __ ] I don't know whatever um
octagonal traveler
[Music]
maybe maybe it will I don't know I'm
probably overthinking it should I go in
the other one what's up with this one
[Music]
can you go up and oh maybe this elevator
brings you down and that just like that
lets you walk in here now that that got
raised I don't [ __ ] know
it's a lot going on in this new area oh
look it's the fire we can't get past
yeah oh sorry yeah so that thing you
just raised would have refilled your
extinguisher the magnums are a no-no
Magnum for us but you have other things
you do key down here believe it's you I
don't think I do I think if I had a fire
extinguisher I would wait what the
door's locked
yeah like I literally can't go down here
at all what did the door say tightly
shut
his head but oh my god I hope someone
gifts that it was um man if I was a
worse person I would be making fun of
you are a terrible person
no I'm letting it slide
oh [ __ ] oh there's another one
[ __ ] come back come back go back
oh nice yeah wah-wah
I haven't been to a change see
I'm gonna hop the new toe
[Music]
please don't have skinnies oh [ __ ] off
what is that I'm gonna die Jesus I don't
know wait you're healthy your helps fine
I think no it's not how was I supposed
to know what the [ __ ] that was hold on
have you done much since you saved I
don't think you've done much I've done a
decent amount in including coming to
this area yeah but you also got hit by
those two zombies that you didn't need
to go toward because the door was
tightly shut
so you haven't you have a few options I
think you could just go right into the
door next to it there's the possibility
that that is self is a safe room let's
find out you totally could I don't know
it could be but you might I don't I hate
that you're poison because I can't tell
if you need to heal I know seems like we
you just have to try to go through the
door that was the loudest I've ever
heard you scream I think I think it's
because I thought it was like a fish
frog because it was water I was like I
hear water well you probably what he's I
think he started in water yeah
definitely sounded like it um well go in
that room what's in that room that blue
hopefully Jesus get it and get out oh my
god yes I'll come back to the store
there's our set high voltage on it it
sure is sure to hit Mike okay I think I
need to heal so I'm going to eat this
blue herb wait wait wait wait you don't
even know what's in this room yet so
what it could be a safe room you have
you in traction but I still need to get
rid of the poison fine I'm angry right
oh yeah you're thank God for that first
aid spray that I would laughs an enemy
came with you right now
what is this wait don't press it what's
the rest what's this room
I don't
no oh it's Avram sweet yeah it is the
saber it is yeah typewriter say box
oh I cocked agonal whole suite more see
way more than I I see it now
there's pucks next to that save I think
I'm gonna save what do you think do the
valve thing first okay there's two
handguns boxes
oh yeah I see them thank you it's very
gray in here
that work tagging it does look octagonal
so that is the current website okay
maybe you can flip that switch now you
still have the valve handle I wonder if
you used to do that what you did with
Claire and like reshape it remember you
like melted it or whatever to be a
gnostic should I do this yeah
oh there's blue in here
I think shotgun shells might able to
almost that's well this has been very
fruitful for Mary considering I almost
just died like a second ago things are
looking up that's for sure my god this
music alright so I feel very much like
oh sorry
those aren't shotgun shells it looks
like the little bucks you'd hold your
pencils in I don't know how the [ __ ]
you're gonna get through that hallway
without killing that sweeper I want to
save I feel very strongly about a lot of
there's a lot of danger in my midst five
o'clock slump you got a coffee I know
but like you you're not gonna be here
next week well cuz I'm gonna be there I
leave Sunday I leave Tuesday and I come
back Thursday so I want to record Friday
if that's okay with you
not Monday I don't think Monday's the
best but I could make it work at all
chanting it right there shotgun shells
in the floor on the other side oh yeah
good job you can look at you can look
into it let me know like I think I could
do Monday but I'd much rather do Friday
cuz my knives did you prep for the trip
that I'm leaving on
can you talk about where you're going
I'm going to LA I'm doing three
different things for Twitter yes
vaguely I am gonna help a really cool
comedian put up his streaming stuff and
hopefully he'll stream because very
funny anybody would know you would know
him I can't oh yeah because I don't know
what's gonna happen - I'm doing a stream
that like is like kind of like the
future of what I think liked which is
capable of which I'm really excited
about but it's experimental
it's about robots and three is also in
the works but it has to do with you'll
be busy to say yeah I'm doing another
stream that I'm not sure if it's gonna
go through yet but if it does it's gonna
be so cool there's mine it'll have
celebra I'm very excited episode really
few more minutes if you want we can dick
around her a little bit just saved
what's down this way you haven't gone
down this should I use my guns should I
use these guys
well you don't even know if you're
hitting I use my intuition
to him he's Nazi Zombies he's not
two of them are dad you're fine you're
good well - Sam I got hurt goddamnit
you could I mean you just saved you
could wipe that if you want and then
come back with a shot what do you think
damn there before guys install with I I
mean we can just I would say we could
call the episode now and then reload and
retry that save yeah you've got help
yeah this I don't call there's so many
[ __ ] guys this what is what's down
this hallway
yeah let's how about that let's reload
from that say for next time we play okay
let me we just finished the job yeah
you don't shoot until you see their
hands ooh that was a double did you see
that yeah I feel like they didn't give
me enough firepower to do this lots of
herbs though in my defense like
like I could basically how is Chris not
cold metal is freezing around him frozen
hey that reminds that's like the when
you get the first floor map and the
first resin evil it's in its end like a
statue like that where are you oh that's
right never mind yeah okay so you're
gonna get ammo after this let's call it
yeah yeah we'll start from there next
time all right
wait one second secret what the [ __ ]
that was horrible
see how scary that was do you recognize
on this stuff it kind of reminds me of
resin evil - oh yes Spencer mansion yeah
I'm just getting spoilers just mad
spoilers for next week I'll let you know
if there's a killer guide down here all
right PlayStation button you dummy
spoiler hi thank you everyone for
joining those president Knievel as
always Mary being her impulsive self
next week is gonna be wild because I got
a kill that ugly guy I got a kill like
12 nazi zombies and I got a kill
whatever that thing is I got a sneak
peek of it looked like a wall I'm gonna
have to kill the wall but yes thank you
everybody we'll have another episode up
next week as always thanks for joining
us thank you a lot of people have been
watching the Code Veronica series
actually yeah it's good stuff some
people to say it's the best cool
well debatably known as it has a good
rest of the weekend everybody watching
this Saturday yeah thanks for stopping
by
[Music]